I want to start with CPAC today the
conservative political action conference
holding their first 2023 event uh
starting Wednesday March 1st now I was
particularly interested in this CPAC
because it was going to allow us to see
what is going to be the approach of this
group
to the 2024 primary at this early stage
where Donald Trump is still in command
we have to admit but there is a
fracturing and there are different
elements of the right some of which like
the idea of more Trump and some of which
are decidedly anti-trump and then
organizations like Fox News were sort of
saying well we'd rather someone else but
we're not going to completely abandon
Trump we're going to wait and see what
would be the mood at CPAC because of all
of these different speakers giving us a
window into the talking points that
would be applied to the 2024 primary or
hypothetically
might the CPAC speakers just ignore the
2024 primary as if it's not going on
sort of ignoring it like an elephant in
the room that nobody wants to talk about
well we are still going to be able to
see but it is going to be with a much
diminished audience and fewer Republican
insiders and the background of all of
this is that a guy named Matt schlapp
who is not exactly a beacon of gay
rights has been credibly accused of
um uh uh what's the right word at
minimum sexual harassment and I believe
it is accurate to say sexual assault of
a male staffer some months ago and it is
believed that this is sort of the black
cloud over the head of CPAC so let's
look at a couple of different articles
explaining what's going on first and
foremost CPAC is being ignored by Fox
News
um one of the biggest outlets for CPAC
getting attention is that Fox News
covers the event interviews people there
promotes the event Etc Daily Beast
writes CPAC has a major Fox News problem
after right-wing power broker Matt
schlapp was accused of sexual assault he
and his annual confab have all but
disappeared from Fox News a shocking
break from years past and it is a break
for shocking you know is sort of
subjective but it is certainly a break
amid the alleged groping scandal
Justin baragona for The Daily Beast
rights over the past few years the
conservative cable giant has not only
aired the entire multi-day conference on
its Digital streaming platform Fox
Nation but the network has also been a
featuring sponsor in 2021 for example
Fox Nation paid a quarter of a million
dollars to help underwrite the overtly
partisan Gathering the year before that
they paid 28 thousand dollars to be a
sponsor as of publication schlapp and
his annual convention have all but
disappeared from the Fox News Universe
none of fox media's Outlets are listed
among their sponsors which includes
their conservative archrival news max as
well as far-right competitors like real
America's voice additionally Fox
staffers told The Daily Beast they have
yet to receive any guidance on how they
will cover CPAC an apparent Fox News
blackout on CPAC would present a
stunning break from past years which
reliably demonstrated a symbiosis
between the cable Giant and the right
wing confab Hannity and Laura Ingram
would often deliver speeches or host
panels which then the network carried
and then outside the ballroom you would
see Fox people walking around it's not
clear whether any of that will be going
on now the context does seem to be the
alleged groping Scandal that I I there
was some speculation that this break
between Fox News and CPAC has more to do
with Trump than it has to do with the
groping Scandal maybe but I've not seen
any actual evidence of that and The
Daily Beast article does mention The
Daily Beast first reported that schlapp
allegedly groped the crotch of a male
staffer
on failed Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker's campaign the
individual this is insane that these is
this is the language that's being used
claimed that Matt schlapp graphed his
quote junk and these terms are all in
quotes and pummeled it at length and it
was scarring and humiliating schlapp is
just denying he's like nah it didn't
happen even though there are text
messages that do seem to show
schlap uncomfortable and and maybe I
don't want to say apologetic but
regretful in some way
um schlap is as far as we know uh
heterosexual and married to a woman so
that is part of the problem that CPAC is
having now there's another story with
this Mike Pence declines invitation
to CPAC as events leader comes Under
Fire this is from ABC News the decision
by Pence who is debating a 2024
presidential run writes ABC News comes
as other notable figures are absent Ron
DeSantis who spoke at CPAC last year has
two events in Texas as CPAC will be
underway in Maryland a spokesperson for
CPAC told ABC News neither Pence nor
DeSantis are currently slated to attend
uh DeSantis a spokesperson didn't
respond and uh Pence didn't attend in
2022 and declined to attend in 2021 the
context here is also believed to be the
sexual assault Scandal Trump is
scheduled to headline the event so I
think that this is actually normally
CPAC is kind of a waste and I don't
typically cover much of it if any
sometimes we've not covered any of it
live my goal this year was actually to
cover the major speeches Live on YouTube
twitch and Facebook again because of the
interest that I have
in seeing how CPAC frames the 2024
Republican primary now one of the things
that may happen by default is there are
with DeSantis and Pence as possible 2024
Republican candidates
snubbing the event and Trump going CPAC
may just default to will praise the hand
that feeds us Trump is coming here to
speak so we will just get behind Trump
but we don't yet have the full agenda I
hope it will be released soon and uh we
will see what the coverage is from Fox
News we will see what the attitude is
towards the primary I'm actually as
interested as I've ever been in uh
covering a CPAC which is not typically
the case
one of our sponsors today is fume fume
is on a mission to accelerate Humanity's
breakup from the bad habits that consume
far too many of us including ones that
harm our health fume is a natural
diffusive device that uses plants and
Behavioral Science to trade out your
negative habit for a positive one fume
is not a vape it's a non-electronic
device designed to transform your
negative habits instead of PODS filled
with potentially harmful chemicals like
a vape fume uses cores infused with
plants like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors fumes new
version 2 model is Snappy and tactile
with an adjustable airflow dial and a
magnetic end cap that's fun to fidget
with its fume's goal to make switching
easy or even enjoyable they have
thousands of five star reviews from
people just like you who have
successfully switched when other
Solutions didn't work head to trifum.com
and use the code Pacman to get 10 off
today when you get the journey pack
which comes with three unique flavors
and the new version to fume the link is
down below